my name is Jason flooger I'm a senior
majoring in chemistry and also the
president of the channel Society which
is an undergraduate chemistry club here
at Columbia I like to tell you a little
about the work that I've been doing for
about past two years in a lab of
professional Scott Snyder who's an
organic chemistry professor here at
Columbia we are interested in the total
synthesis of natural products
specifically natural derivatives of the
molecules verra troll roars very troll
is canon red wine and it's a potential
explanation for the so-called French
paradox which describes the observation
that despite eating a diet high in fat
cholesterol the French have a relatively
low incidence of heart disease and
indeed resveratrol initially being
strong antioxidant shows a wide variety
of in vitro and in vivo activity against
inflammation heart disease aging and
cancer specifically I'm interested in
the toll synthesis of the derivative hi
Mia leg which is shown here it is
actually not as biologically active is
as their troll and many other natural
products but it's very structurally
interesting it poses a unique synthetic
challenge for our group and our strategy
is more of a global strategy towards
access in the entire family from a
single common intermediate through which
we believe that can access any
derivative of resveratrol including
these five which road even synthesized
by the group in addition to many others
is hopefully several more on the way the
comments meat itself is the synthesis of
which is shown here it's actually very
easy to make in very high yield it only
requires purification at the last step
and the comment we made in very pure and
very high yields while this compound is
the official intermediate for the group
I'm going to oxidize it to the ketone
and treat this compound is need
immediate for the work that I'm about to
tell you about over the course of the
past two years we've gone through three
major approaches towards accessing this
natural product the first involved first
psych lysing with this compound called
trifluoromethyl dioxin related as DM do
followed by
we envision adding this compound and
using grignard reagent which we can
enclose the ring using a DBQ pencilling
oxidation this slide just shows the
mechanism for our novel cyclization
using DM do which initially presents us
with a few problems the first being that
the yield of the reaction is very low at
best it is thirty percent typically
yields are even lower it's a
temperamental reaction so sometimes it
just doesn't work at all in addition the
stereochemistry of these two positions
is anti meaning one is up and one is
down whereas to access a natural product
both of them need to be on the same side
either both up or both down and so that
adds in a two additional steps later on
down the line to oxidize then reduce to
get us the right stereochemistry
ultimately those and several other
difficulties led us to look for other
routes towards the natural product as
this route very cumbersome and very low
yielding very quickly our second
approach involved a fairly ambitious
double cyclization attempt where we
would accomplish making this ether and
the seven membered ring at the same time
in the same reaction flask that compound
here could be prepared from grignard
addition into this aldehyde which in
turn can be made from the core jackowski
epoxidation zinc iodide opening of our
starting intermediate key town
ultimately we were not able to get this
double cyclization to proceed and even
though we tried to take a step back and
do it more stepwise we cannot even get
the single step seven membered cycle
station to proceed as it had done in our
first approach and ultimately this route
proved unfeasible sort of accidental
discovery gave us her inspiration for
what became our third major approach
which we worked on this past summer and
that was while going through the cordial
castles and iodide we got a fairly major
side product which we initially
characterized to be this seven membered
compound which at the time we made it we
just thought that we could take that to
em plops an f weird is a natural product
that already been synthesized by the
group and so it wasn't a priority for us
more just a mental exercise however I'm
comparing the natural products who
realized that em plops an F and
my mom kiss my mule a are different only
in this oxygen atom in this bridge
system and so are the question then
became can we add an option into this
ring to get us to this compound to then
take this too honey la instead and our
attempt to answer that was the buyer
villiger oxidation which is this
reaction here by oxidizing the alcohol
up to the ketone we can then do what's
known as dabar villiger oxidation to add
this oxygen into the ring either on this
side or that side and luckily we got I
one to one mix of each isomers where the
oxygen added equally to the desired and
the undesired side which is actually
better than we would expect it just from
looking at the molecule on paper two
steps remain to complete the molecule
first was a dive I'll reduction which
when in quantitative yield to get this
lacked hall followed by a friedel-crafts
addition of the remaining arrow ring
which gave us a very unexpected product
the NMR spectrum which is our major way
of characterizing these compounds only
had half the number of peaks that it
should have had one possible answer to
this is that we lost half the molecule
but upon taking a mass using mass
spectroscopy we realized that we have
the mass of the desired compound and so
are other explanation is that the
molecule somehow perfectly symmetrical
which can't happen in desired compound
Jaime leg so that led us to go back and
reevaluate our intermediates to see
where we had mischaracterized something
and it turns out it was in that side
product from that first reaction that we
mischaracterized and what we believe
actually happened is that the aldehyde
exists as a fairly significant
contribution in the enol tautomer and
it's by rotating around this bond you
get this structure which is perfectly
set up for a 6 electron cyclization
which can then be closed by this arrow
ring giving us this 6 membered product
rather than our seven membered ring that
we would expect which when doing the
chemistry that we done would get us to
this perfectly symmetrical product the
bright side of that is that the
chemistry worked you're just doing on
the wrong compound
until the task then became to get it
really anything to mediate along the way
such that we could use the chemistry
that we've already done to get at the
natural product and so where we are
right now is to kind of create that
missing link between our starting
materials and the reactions that'll get
us to the product using the aldehyde
which we can get from our core Jocasta
zinc iodide reaction we can oxidize that
using the Pinta sedation to the
carboxylic acid and I'm currently
attempting various Idol lactam ization
and similar conditions to generate the
desired lactone in a single step from
which we can use the chemistry that
we've already established namely the
reduction in the friedel-crafts addition
to get us at our natural product and so
that's currently where the product is
that now and the work that I'm currently
doing and hopefully we'll be able to
finish in the near future is I'm
wrapping up I'd like to thank the Snyder
group particularly pressure scott snyder
and nathan wright who is sort of my
graduate co-worker on the project as
well as the main chemical society
division we're going to chemistry for a
fellowship to sponsor me over the summer
through which my corporate sponsor was
Novartis and of course the colombian
dorset chemistry department for their
constant support and resources in my
research thank you